للحصول على الذخيره التي هي في امس الحاجه
اليها تتطلع اوكرانيا مباشره الى واشنطن
الا ان المفاوضين من الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ فشلوا في
التوصل الى اتفاق بخصوص اقرار حزمه
المساعدات لكيف والبالغه قيمتها 61 مليار
دولار ليس لدينا سوى خيار واحد علينا ان
ننجح ان المخاطر كبيره للغايه بالنسبه
لامريكا واوروبا والشرق الاوسط والعالم
علينا ان نرسل المزيد من المساعدات الى
اوكرانيا لهزيمه
بوتين اعتقد ان هذا هو اخطر وقت منذ سقوط
جدار برلين لذلك لا شك ان هذه الحزمه مهمه
للغايه والجزء الاكثر تعقيدا منها في
الواقع هي
الحدود يامل المشرعون ان تتحقق هذه الخطوه
مطلع العام المقبل على الرغم من الحاح
البيت الابيض على المشرعين بسرعه اقرارها
المساعدات الدفاعيه لا تقتصر فقط على
ارسال المساعدات الى اوكرانيا هي تتضمن
مساعدات لاسرائيل وتايوان هذا وربت
الجمهوريون دعمهم بتشديد سياسه الهجره
الامريكيه اذ يريد الجمهوريون المزيد من
الرقابه على الطريقه التي يتم بها انفاق
اموال دافع الضرائب الامريكيين الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي الذي زار
الكونجرس في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر حث مره
اخرى المشرعين الامريكيين على مواصله
تقديم
الذخيره ث ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لن تخوننا وان ما اتفقنا عليه سيتم تنفيذه
بالكامل دام اوكرانيا اولويه قصوى بالنسبه
للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ولهذا فان
المحادثات المتوقفه في الكونجرس يرى انها
انتكاسه